ration 22: 8 to9 let's read that I John
and the one who heard and saw these
things and when I heard and saw them I
fell down to worship at the feet of the
Angel who showed them to me but he said
to me you must not do that I am a fellow
servant with you what am I a fellow
servant emphasize all I am is a servant
like you John I'm not greater than you
I'm not your Lord I'm not your master
and you're not my servant I like you am
a servant for the sake of God Amen so
who do you worship finish it I am a
fellow servant with you and your
brothers the prophets and with those who
keep the words of this book worship God
that's all you worship is God alone you
do not worship me I a slave no more no
less you know what's interesting as a
side note John makes this mistake twice
not once this is the second time that
John almost lapsed into idolatry did you
know that mhm this is the second time
the first time was Revelation 19:10 I
want to use that as an illustration to
show you that even the best of saints
are capable of being the worst of
Sinners so that you do not put your hope
in any man or any woman you have to put
your undivided trust and hope and love
in God and God Alone amen because even
the greatest of the apostles were prone
to committing the worst sins imaginable
and here John you think the first time
when he's rebuked he would get it the
angel tells him the first time in
Revelation 19:10 don't worship me John
and yet when he sees the angel again he
again is a on the verge of lapsing into
worshiping the angel you think he got it
the first time because in Revelation
19:10 what does the angel tell him
Revelation 19:10 then I fell down at his
feet to worship him but he said to me
you must not do that I am a fellow
servant with you and your brothers who
hold to the testimony of Jesus worship
God for the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of Prophecy I'll explain that
last part in a minute now notice this
was the first time he was tempted to
worship an Angelic creature and the
Angelic creature rebuked him don't do it
John I'm just a servant like you don't
make me more than I am worship God alone
you think John would learned the lesson
the first time and yet when he sees this
glorious Angel whether it's the same
angel or different Angel the second time
again again he lapses into idolatry what
does that tell you the best of saints
can be the worst of Sinners and even the
greatest Apostles can commit the worst
imaginable sins if it isn't the grace of
God protecting them
amen now why do you think the Lord
allowed for John to lapse into idolatry
not once and but twice and God saving
him from that idolatry and recorded in
Revelation as a lesson for us that as
great as John is he's still a flesh and
blood human being prone to sin so your
hope is not in John your hope is in the
god of John who can never fail you amen
is there with me there that's what
you're supposed to learn from these two
instances in which John was about to
lapse into idolatry do not make any man
any preacher Any teacher even Billy
Graham I don't care who it is do not
make them more than they are because at
the end of the day they are Flesh and
Blood Sinners capable of committing the
most heinous sins against God if the
Holy Spirit doesn't protect them
amen so your
love attention trust and undivided
devotion is to be directed to God and
God Alone no matter how much you love
that man of God who speaks truth in your
life that man of God can still fail you
that man of God unfortunately and God
forbid can still fall into Wicked sins
even adultery or immorality what you
name it he's capable of doing it because
like you he's Flesh and Blood that's
right love him respect him but don't put
your hope in him your hope is in Christ
and Christ Alone amen hallelujah go to
Jeremiah 17 5-7 for
confirmation Jeremiah 17:5 says I want
you to see that even the best of saints
are capable of committing the worst of
sins don't believe me look at the life
of King David King David slept with a
married woman commit adultery got her
pregnant and murdered the husband to
cover over his crime and shame and this
was God's anointed king filled with the
spirit a man after God's Own Heart why
do you think these stories are there to
teach you your hope and trust is not in
David it's not in Solomon it's not in
Abraham it's not in Samson it's not in
Paul who's my hero by the way your hope
and trust has to be in Christ and Christ
alone because although he's a man he's
more than a man he's God Almighty In the
Flesh and Christ can never never fail
you amen
never because as God he's completely
reliable and trustworthy right amen but
that cannot be said of any of us right
read Jeremiah 17: 5-7 I don't mean to sh
but I'm little up CU I want the people
in the back to hear me not because I
have anger issues I'm the most happy
person you'll ever meet in your life
read for me Jeremiah 175 to7 thus says
Yahweh cursed is the man who trusts in
man and makes flesh his strength whose
heart turns away from Yahweh he is like
a shrub in the desert and shall not see
any good come he shall dwell in the
parts places of the Wilderness in an un
in an uninhabited salt land so what
happens to you when you trust in flesh
and make man your hope your
strength what's going to happen to you
what happens to you he looking at me
you're like oh yeah I know you're
admiring my good books but I mean what
happens to you you shall dwell in the
parched places of the Wilderness in
other words you will wither you will die
you will fail right because that man
whether you like it or not that woman
will fail you so never give anyone your
heart unconditionally except Jesus
Christ your lord right once you give
Christ your heart unconditionally he
will preserve it perfectly by his
infinite power give it to human being
and it's only a matter of time before
they crush your heart and walk all over
you because we are double-minded and
comous that's our nature until Christ
glorifies us now continue reading to
seven and then eight Who Who Are you
supposed to trust blessed is the man who
trusts in Yahweh whose trust is Yahweh
Hallelujah you are blessed when Yahweh
is your trust your hope your strength
your love you are blessed why because
unlike that person who trusts in a
fellow human being only to be
disappointed and heartbroken God will
never fail you that's why if you go to
eight what he says he is like a tree
planted by water that sends out its
roots by the stream and does not fear
when he comes praise the Lord for its
leaves remain green and is not anxious
in the year of drought for it does not
cease to bear fruit because God will
sustain You Forever by The Living Waters
the holy spirit so you get it why these
stories of these Great Men of God
failing so miserably are there to teach
you a lesson do not make any man of God
or even woman of God because you have
sisters look to
women as their role models God does this
to show you even the best of saints can
commit the worst crimes against God so
you give no one and Ken is going to be
patient not talk out of turn you give no
one your undivided attention and
devotion except the Living God father
son holy spirit amen father son Holy
Spirit right in fact if you read the
stories of some of these Saints the last
thing you would think is that they were
Saints if the Bible didn't tell you for
example if you read the story of Samson
had it not been for Hebrews 11 you'd
question whether he was saved the story
of by the way I encourage you to go see
the movie Samson is out the theaters new
version of Samson do you guys know that
oh yeah have you seen it no I want to go
see it because would like to support the
film I'm always disappointed with
Hollywood did you see it no I'm just
always I I saw it it's it's what it's
disappointing see this is this thank the
Lord I put my hope and trust in
you so I'll just take your opinion with
you know no I'm K but he said then I'll
just wait for DVD G thank you for
raining on My Parade there goes my
Saturday tomorrow but anyway coming back
to the issue Samson if you read his
story he did everything contrary to the
one not he got drunk he parted he even
married a foreign woman a Philistine
woman and on top of that judges 16:1
says that Samson went to Gaza to find to
sleep with her he actually slept with a
prostitute that judges 16
verse1 so if you had read a story you'd
think this man is anything but a saint
of God and yet in Hebrews 11 he's
mentioned as one of those who had Faith
pleasing to God he's mentioned by name
in Hebrews 11 as a man who had faith
that pleased god wow
now that gives hope to the rest of us
right man he can make it we can make it
because at the end of the day you're not
saved by Your Righteous Deeds you're say
by the righteousness of the Lord Jesus
Christen and his blood is more powerful
than any sin you can commit provided you
turn to him and trust in him for
salvation and forgiveness amen amen